hello everyone and welcome to round
eight of the 2022 tata still chess
tournament it's shakira mamijarov versus
pragyananda and it's uh quite a quite a
lovely game a lot a lot of action
happening prague was playing a very very
interesting chess as it would seem but
uh shakira doesn't back down from a
challenge you'll see in this game uh
we're skipping the magnus game for round
eight as it was pretty much a snooze
fest he played against the shankland and
shankland is an incredibly solid player
uh nothing pretty much was happening in
that game they just traded some pieces
and agreed to a draw uh to put it mildly
so we are not going to cover that one uh
this is the one that we are going to
cover and as tomorrow is the rest they
were going to cover some other games
that we didn't have time to cover so
mamedyarov with the white pieces opens
with c4 he goes for the english opening
we have e5 by prague uh we have uh g3
and now c6 uh we have d4 and here prague
advances the pawn uh all the way to e4
with some ideas of of playing d5 uh
making white's bishop to g2 idea not all
that impressive so here mommy thereof
plays queen to a4 it's a very tricky
move and the position is already a very
rare one uh he's saying if you play d5
uh your c pawn will be pinned and then
i'm just going to play c captures on d5
but interestingly this is exactly what
prague plays
and already we can see that it's going
to be a very enjoyable game so okay
mamidyarov accepts the challenge c
captures on d5 and now there are a
couple of games where knight to f6 was
played but here prague plays b
not b6 b5
and it is now already as of move 5 that
we have a completely new game so this is
how he he does it he attacks the queen
and what can mamidyarov do now or or is
there or are there even some problems uh
well he goes queen to b3 uh and now
knight to f6 just continuing development
uh we have bishop the g5 and you could
also maybe try to capture some points
but mamiyarov doesn't want to be left
behind in development uh and then now
comes queen to a5 with check
if you want to play a
sort of a solid solid line maybe queen
captures and d5 is is a bit
more
uh pleasant for black but it doesn't
seem that uh prague has any problems um
not playing crazy lines the idea is
after bishop captures on f6 and queen
captures here a captures g captures and
now let's say knight to c3 we get at
this position where black has doubled f
pawns white has double b pawns uh and
it's a pretty enjoyable uh position for
both of them but uh we decide to keep
the queens on the board queen to a5
would check knight to c3 blocking and
now b4 chasing away this knight knight
back to d1 and here only now knight
captures on the uh d5 and you you have
to be careful now there are a lot of
tricks in the position you have to be
wary of this bishop hanging on g5 if the
knight ever moves so here we have bishop
to h3 attacking the bishop on c8 as it's
undefended so here prague traits we have
captures captures in the now knight to
d7
uh as uh there aren't any tricks now the
knight here guards the the bishop on g5
uh rook the c1 and now h6 uh challenging
the bishop here asking where where are
you going to move it this should make
the d2 now putting more pressure on this
b4 pawn maybe a3 and is an idea at some
point so rook to c8 and now comes an
incredibly strong move and that is f3
asking how are you dealing with f
captures on e4
now the idea behind e captures on f3 for
example he captures on f3 is queen
captures on f3 and there are a lot of uh
interesting lines here but to give you
an example let's say bishop d6 black
continuous development we're going to
castle and now if black castles which
seems like something you'd really want
to do the problem is the knight and d7
is undefended and white can use this to
his advantage
for example he can already start with
bishop captures on h6 and black's
position is very very difficult to
defend the g captures on h6 queen g4
check you could capture the knight here
but
for example if uh
king to h8 we're gonna continue the
attack with queen to h5 but even if king
the h7
we don't have to capture the knight we
can even play knight to g5 check for
example captures queen delivers checking
g7 queen captures and g5 check for
example king h7 queen h4 and now with
some rook at five rook to h5 ideas um
should be uh very quickly over for black
so instead after f3 we have knight seven
to f6 uh just continuing development and
now knight to f2 putting more pressure
on the e4 pawn so captures is definitely
an idea here so e captures on f3 and now
what do you do well of course e4 that's
the whole point grabbing the full center
and chasing the knight away from the d5
square i just have to let middle in
he's a weird dude i always ask him does
he want to come upstairs when i uh go
here to record and then he doesn't want
to come and then he just barges in at
you know
during the video so here after e4 it's
again an incredibly tricky position and
if handled well uh prague will only be
slightly worse but prague will plays
knight to b6 and that is a problem uh
you have to take this opportunity to
play queen b5 and threaten checkmate
that's the good stuff here uh queen
captures on f3 and the nago knight to c7
and now it's still hard for black but
but it's playable for example e5 knight
f to d5 and after knight to e3 we can
trade captures captures uh the position
is uh not pleasant for black there's the
opponent c6 hanging white has a full
center and
uh
it's it's not uh great but at least you
are preventing white from castling the
queen covering this diagonal is uh is is
a good one for uh for black you can play
bishop e7 you can castle and maybe you
can survive this however uh prague
started with knight to b6 and this
allows madero to just keep all the
advantages that we've already discussed
uh plus he will castle the safety so
here he starts with castles uh we have
bishop to e7 and now knight to e3 the
knight coming to f5 will be just a a
monster piece so queen to a4 offering a
queen trade because if you don't offer a
queen trade again if you just castle
we're gonna play knight to f5 and look
at this over overloaded bishop here how
do you defend it uh if you move it for
example if you move bishop d8 then we
play bishop captures on b4 attack the
queen and the rook kind of f8 so it
doesn't matter what you play here it's
just winning or if rook defense bishop
we just capture it and bishop captures
on b4 it's completely winning so prague
says all right we have to trade queens
first uh at least this will mitigate
some of the danger so queen to d3 uh of
course mamidarov keeps the queens on the
board uh and now queen b5 uh offering a
queen trade again and now okay queen
captures on b5 we have c captures on b5
rook captures on c8 knight captures in
the now e5 uh chasing away this knight
knight to d7 and now knight to f5
putting pressure on the knight on the g7
pawn so really controlling just a a
whole lot of squares here i just the
simple idea of knight captures on e7
king or knight captures and then bishop
captures on b4 is already
quite a lot for for white as white's
position is better the f3 pawn is also
weak so we're going to capture that as
well so g6 is played here
asking uh do you want to waste a move
capturing the pawn on h6 so maybe i can
develop my pieces a little bit maybe i
get the open h file for my rook uh but
mamadyarov just plays the very strong
rook to c1 i'm not interested in that
pawn he goes after the knight and c8 we
have knight to d to b6 sorry knight d to
b6 um the defending the knight here and
now comes knight captures an e7 you
could capture the pawn it's perfectly
fine uh but mamidyarov decides to do it
like this he he wants to capture here
and then grab the b for pawn so knight
captures an e7 bishop captures on b4 and
now knight b to d5 just going after that
bishop bishop captures an e7 mommy there
are happily trades we have king captures
on e7 and not knight to e4 and this is
the position now
as you can see the uh the material is
equal but uh white's position is uh it
is definitely to be preferred the strong
center here uh the ability to go after
the f pawn it's just much much better
the rook already controlling the only
open file on the board so these are the
advantages that white has so here we
have g5 uh prague really wants to play
g4 if he can play g4 then he has a
protected pawn on f3 and that's going to
be great for him but of course mamadarov
does not allow this he plays h3 and now
again prague has that one little moment
where it's uh possible to
well
relieve the suffering uh but it's uh
it's not an easy move to find but you
guys can try to find it so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
best move for prague in the position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on spotting the
right move uh and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is pawn
to f5 that's that's right and we're
gonna discuss why this is so uh i
probably grabbed the df pawn but he
advanced it only one square he played
pawn to f6 but pawn to f5 is better
because it chases away the knight from
uh from this square and now you can't
really you can't really allow this
because then g4 it just happens and you
have a protected pass pawn on f3 then
this will be good for black so we're
going to have to capture e captures on
f6 alpha song and now we're going to
have a trade here for example captures
captures and captures and now this is
the position where if played perfectly
it is most likely a draw for example
king f2 we go after the pawn rook d8 we
go after this pawn and now white will
not give up this past pawn so now h5
threatening g4 and now
white has to play g for himself for
example captures captures and now this
is the position that would definitely
happen if f5 was played it's not
pleasant for black but it's uh
probably manageable so instead probably
played f6 now it's different because
white can choose to ignore this as the
knight is not being threatened so here
just um
rook to c5 going after the knight and
the pawn on b5 uh and now prague will
plays f5 so kind of wasting a tempo
there but
what are you gonna do uh we have uh you
don't want to allow the trade here if
captures captures then again the pawn on
f3 is defended this is now well almost
winning for black so instead we have
knight to d2 getting out of the way now
threatening to pick up the pawn but also
black's knight here is hanging so you do
not have time to play g4 uh that's what
mamadara was going for so rook to d8
defending the knight but now of course
we play knight captures on f3
and we win a pawn so here b4
and king to f2 now it's time to start
bringing the king into the game
knight to b6 and now rook to c6 going
after the h6 spawn and you don't really
gain anything by advancing it for
example if h5 you can play b3 and now if
g4 now doesn't matter captures
characters we're going to play knight h4
and you don't have uh rook captures on
d4 because well knight the knight f5
check picks up the rook so without root
captures on d4 you really don't have all
that much uh it would be again winning
uh uh a winning position for white so
after rook the c6 rook the c8 was played
trying to trade off the the rooks or if
rook captures on h6 then we go for uh
rook to c to check so here mommy daryl
just trades rook captures knight
captures in the now h4
now he allows g4 but there is no more a
pawn on f3 uh that you have to worry
about so g4 knight to e1 and now knight
to b6 we have this in game uh where
mamijarov is up upon
uh but it's uh it's a very important
pawn plus the central pawns are both uh
past pawns so uh
incredibly difficult to play against
this so knight the g2 we have knight to
the a4 going after the b2 pawn but now
just knights to e3 not only attacking
the f5 pawn now with a tempo uh but also
just getting ready if black defends this
for example with king e6 we can also
play knight c4 defender b2 point we're
going to play b3 and everything is
perfectly fine for white so after knight
e3 prague decides to capture on b2 but
now we have knight captures on f5 check
king is six and now knight captures on
h6 knight to d1 check
kink the e1 not knight to c3 we have
knight captures on g4 and the knight
captures on a2 and now uh mamadirov just
starts advancing his pawn pawn to h5 and
even though prague has a pawn on b4
already the problem is the king is well
within the center of the
uh
square of the pawn and
there's simply no no way you can
do this the problem is if b3 king d2 and
now you don't have the c3 square for the
knight you need the knight on c3 to
defend the b1 square and there's nothing
you can do b2 king c2 you are never
queening the spawn so prague starts with
knight to c3 now he's hoping for b3 and
b2 but just king to d2 and of course
there's nothing to be done here 94
checking to c2 and he was in this
position on mu 46 that prague resigned
in the game and this is now a third
victory in a row for shahrir mahmud
yarov who catches up to magnus carlsen
who was in seoul lead uh even after
today's draw with samuel shanklin now
it's uh carlson versus mamidarov drawn
uh
they're drawn for first place uh sorry
tied for first place and they are
playing uh
around eight uh in round eight together
so it's gonna be a clash of leaders so a
very very
uh um uh enjoyable game in coming i i
presume but you never know we'll we'll
see what happens magnus does have the
white pieces so he will definitely be
pushing for for more than a draw
so yeah here we resign uh because let's
say knight captures on g3 we play h6 and
after king f7 even e6 check and that's
it it's impossible to keep an eye on
both both of the pawns if you uh push
the king here then just e7 and of course
if you capture h7 you cannot capture the
pawn
so yeah after king to c2 prague resigned
and a wonderful wonderful victory for
shakhtar mamidyarov
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
malaki heavenhan ron swanson thomas earl
carly simmer and david kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it ends thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day